so this sort of idiocy leads to the kind
of policies that we have seen in the
state of California my home state so the
state of California has not suffered
from a massive outbreak the state of
California has last I checked something
like seven deaths per 100,000 citizens
in the state of California a grand total
in in the state of California California
Cova 19 tests last I checked were under
3,000 deaths statewide we have 40
million citizens in the state of
California we have 2770 confirmed deaths
from covin 19 in the state of California
according to sort of the numbers that
Google is popping up for me here right
now okay so those are not massive
incredibly large numbers and though
those are every death is a tragedy every
death is bad but California is not the
center of this outbreak I guess it's up
to 2880 to according to the LA Times
okay that's that's terrible it's bad and
we should be careful when we reopen but
the state of California has basically
decided that we are now engaged in a in
a kindergarten game of one-upsmanship
and it was pretty obvious that this is
how things were gonna go when the
lockdown is originally occurred right
San Francisco lockdown and then
immediately thereafter la lockdown and
then immediately thereafter New York
lockdown and so it's gonna be the other
way around right you're seeing one game
of follow-the-leader when it comes to
reopening when some state saying listen
we gotta reopen or our economy's gonna
die other states are saying listen we're
not gonna be blamed right if you're
gavin newsom if you want to avoid
scrutiny what you say at this point is
we're never gonna reopen ever right
we're not reopening until there's a
vaccine if you're JB Pritzker Nolan Oy
vaccine because I'm not gonna be blamed
for one excess death I'm not gonna be
blamed for any sort of excess death now
here's the reality politicians cannot
lock down this way
Americans are just not going to stand
for it and they're particularly not
gonna lock down in the idiotic fashion
that is now being promoted by a Los
Angeles state government so California
is saying well why don't we let people
decide on a county-by-county basis just
gonna point out when Donald Trump says
that according to the states when he
says States should decide vocalism
should rule he's very bad when Gavin
Newsom says County should decide on a
county-by-county basis then Gavin
Newsome apparently according to the
media is very very good but according to
county public health director Barbara
Ferrer she said at Tuesday's Board of
Supervisors meeting based on her
community relations degree from UC Santa
Cruz based on all the data we're looking
we know with certainty we'll be
extending health off officer orders for
the next three months three months the
stay-at-home restrictions orders will be
in place for three months how do you
even know that how can you
we couldn't forecast this thing two
weeks out Ferrer said while the safer at
home waters will remain in place over
the next few months restrictions will be
gradually relaxed under the county's
existing roadmap to recovery we're
counting on the public's continued
compliance with the orders to enable us
to relax restrictions they say that
instead of the LA County Board of
Supervisors is trying to claim that they
were that they were taken out of context
because the original statement is that
the stay at home owners would remain in
place as is for three months Mayor Eric
Garcetti said I think quite simply she's
saying we're not gonna fully reopen Los
Angeles and probably anywhere in America
without any protections or any health
orders in the next three months I think
it's gonna be even longer than three
months okay that's not what the original
statement was the original statement was
he stay at home orders are going to
remain in place for three months until
the end of July which is patently insane
it means the end of the economy of Los
Angeles has everybody well understands
and as it turns out the policies that
are being promulgated in LA are
completely idiotic so are the policies
in California for reopening counties
I'll explain the policies okay here are
some of the policies the policies
according to the LA Times at the beaches
you ready for this how people can use
this and will look different face
coverings will be required when not in
the water
sunbathing won't be allowed only active
recreation surfing running walking and
swimming will be permitted coolers
chairs umbrellas and any of the other
accessories that typically dot the
shoreline should be left at home do
people understand like why masks are
useful or why being outside is good or
why social distancing is useful so the
idea is what I'm gonna like take my kids
to the beach I'm gonna pop open that
back door I'm gonna take my kids I'm
going to walk down with them to the
water throw them in the water take them
out of the water walk back to the cars
shove them inside like what the hell are
you talking about doesn't how beaches
work what are you talking about and if
I'm if I got a 20-foot radius around me
and I'm sitting there on the sand
explain to me how that's a bad thing
explain explain me why I need to wear a
face mask when I'm socially to sensing
from other people there's literally no
reason I don't need to wear a face mask
if I am outside in the Sun the Sun by
the way which does kill the virus
according to best available evidence and
I'm ten feet away from everybody else
like this is madness but that's not the
that's not even the extent of the
stupidity so according to Gavin Newsom
standard
there are two criteria as to which
counties can move into reopening phases
whether deaths have stopped completely
in the last 14 days from cover 19 and
whether there is no more than one case
per 10,000 residents in that same time
period most of California failed that
test in fact 95 percent of Californians
live in counties that don't meet that
standard
The Times analysis found not a single
County in Southern California nor the
San Francisco Bay Area met the criteria
deaths have stopped for 14 days deaths
have stopped for 14 days okay let me let
me just ask a quick question um has
anybody in California has there been any
any place in California like LA County
let's take out Wake County what le
counts you have to shut down for the
actual flu okay this is more dangerous
than the flu this is always my
stipulation because people in the media
get very uptight when you mentioned the
flu in the same sentence as covered so
let it be known kovat is more dangerous
than the flu and more transmissible but
I'm pointing out and we are not shutting
down from the flu in LA County there has
not been a week in California for six
years where somebody did not die of the
flu
here is a chart provided to you by LA
County which shows that it turns out
people die of the flu every single week
every week from 2014 to present right
this is pneumonia and influenza as a
percent of all deaths LA County 2013 in
2014 to 2019 2020 so what the hell are
you talking about there won't be a death
for 48 you know how many people live in
LA County there are 10 million people in
LA County so you're telling me that
until there's not one Cove in 19 death
in all of LA County so I guess like in a
hundred years when several generations
of Los Angelenos have died then I guess
we can reopen according to these
standards this is just madness it's
complete and utter insanity meanwhile
California State University is going to
teach remotely in the fall they're not
gonna let the students go back to school
why well they can't explain it because
the reality is that young people are not
in particularly terrible shape in fact
young people are in particularly good
shape if you're vulnerable you should
stay off campus and mitch Daniels who's
the president / / dude the Dean / Purdue
he said we're gonna reopen and we're
going to take precautions for people who
are vulnerable this would be the
rational solution but we cannot pursue
rationality and in any way it's locked
down infinity
locked out and then locked down infinity
plus one that's the way this is gonna
work for a lot of politicians when the
media set up a standard such that
reopening is considered you
green-lighting death it is not a shock
that politicians respond to that
political incentive by saying okay let's
lock down forever and as you'll see
that's exactly what Joe Biden is doing
the Democrats are naturally glomming
onto the media the media calculus here
the Democrats continue to push lock
downs that move beyond the possibility
of any sort of real calibrated response
it's not as what they've set a timeline
that's in any way realistic and that LA
County timeline is insane 14 days with
no deaths from Cova 19 how about 14 days
with no deaths from a car accident
before we can get back on the roads like
this is that's not it's just nuts ok but
you have Eric Garcetti saying Americans
want us to get it right yes we do you
know what getting it right looks like
allowing people back like there will not
be a functioning economy in the city of
Los Angeles and if you think that all
you're gonna do is just tax the rich
people in all I guess what rich people
have the capacity to do move to leave
they're the only people in LA you have
the capacity to leave here's mayor
Garcetti most Americans want us to get
it right you look at polls across the
country certainly here in Los Angeles
it's go slow don't go fast and get it
right so we don't have to retreat so she
wanted to make sure that I communicated
and what she was communicating is that
we still need to have a public health
order because there are some populations
who will need to stay at home people
need to know whatever possible it is
safer to stay at home so if you can
telecommute etcetera and there's no
radical changes in the next week coming
ok so again when he says that people
want to go slow nobody is defining these
terms go slow nobody is defining what
exactly that looks like all the polls
are extraordinarily vague about which
exact policies people approve of people
are basically on board with them asking
people are basically on board with the
social distancing but very few people
are on board with these let's just stay
in lockdown until the end of time did
you know that every like on this video
creates one additional leftist year
don't ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity hit the like button